je crois vous avez à côté de vous madame
gilbert qui a personnellement vous avez
souffert madame des persécutions pendant
la guerre et vous avez souffert de
l'antisémitisme pouvez vous nous
raconter en quelques mots oui c'est ça a
commencé à l'école en quelque sorte je
crois que il faut soit que vous aviez
quel âge madame à cette époque là en 30
ans 38 42 en france ça a commencé en
quelle année
à quel moment vous a tant fait pour que
le port de l'étoile c'était en 42 1 42 j
porter l'étoile j'avais 14 ans mais
j'avais ma jeune soeur qui avait 9 ans
elle enfin y'a pas d'âge un tout petit
porter l'étoile
et puis il y avait des tas
d'interdiction qui est allé vers les
interdictions qui tient par exemple il
avait le l'interdiction d'aller au
cinéma de de rentrer chez soi après 8
heures le soir de prendre seulement
enfin le dernier wagon dans le métro
dans le métro
interdiction de prendre le train de se
déplacer en dehors de la circonscription
d'entrer dans un jardin j'aurais pu lui
était réservée aux non juifs
oui d'entrer dans des magasins à
certaines heures enfin tout un tas de
choses j'ai même été envoyée d'une école
tout nous était interdit et si nous
faisions une infraction enfin
nous ne respections pas celle ci
règlement bon bah c'était la peine de
mort en fait puisque nous risquions la
déportation et de toute la famille si un
seul membre commettez un délit c'était
toute la famille qui était arrêté et
déporté à 14 ans comment une petite
fille pouvait-elle comprendre cela le
port de l'étoile jaune de le croiser le
port de l'étoile au début pour moi ça a
été en fait c'était l'humiliation
l'humiliation la révolte et puis la
puissance et puis bon on opte j'osais
plus regarder les gens mais par la suite
en observant mieux j'ai eu l'impression
que les gens étaient plus gêné que moi
même
[Musique]